avec vous lucienne forget pas une petite
question de petites séries
voici le premier thème les dix plus
grands lacs du monde
alors les siennes avec qui voulez vous
jouer regardez les codes qui sont là
avec vous l'assuré d'un grand
spécialiste en laque 22 des grands lacs
du monde daniel alors en chic
comment ils ne seraient pas de souffler
plus fort tu es du lac érié le/la
attendait oui lac daumesnil non comme du
bois de boulogne
le lac est la cause pour écouter
attendez laissez moi réfléchir l'ontario
ontario le lac ontario
oui moi vos comms en or dans le lac
lochte a beau les gens qui n'ont pas
invoqué près du congo belge
les mains le lac léman si nous laissons
le lac monia
le lac bout janot oui oui exact le lac
mono michka exact le lac mais rooney v
exact le lac dont brisbane ce mardi
n'est pas terminée le lac monge classes
venues de formuler un daniel provost est
jolie et j'ajoute si le temps me reste
un tout petit peu le trac colons
vigouroux nous est enfin à nouveau la
queue qui est actuellement en vente des
grands magasins blacks semblent et oreo
oreillons au rayon casseroles
extraordinaire bienvenue ou daniel
prévost nous sommes médusés par votre
culture malheureusement certes tous les
lacs oumma et cités sont bons mais
c'était après la petite sonnerie pour
mémoire je peux tout faire vous citez
c'est la mémoire de qui le lac supérieur
lac victoria michigan tanganyka le lac
tchad lac huron baïkal la ligue arabe et
le lourd gelé bien j'ai dit ça mais j'ai
dit tout ça dans la langue des pays à
d'autres thèmes les os de la jambe et du
pied